is it possible to fully replace an actor
with CGI the short answer is yes but
there's always a human performance
driving it so what happens when the
performance parts is no longer necessary
will we see acting go away I hope not
that would suck but the writers and
actors currently on strike though this
has become a big conversation these
communities are feeling scared and for
good reason Tech is advancing quickly
and there's no regulation or Safety Net
in place and where there's fear there's
misinformation too that's why I wanted
to take an honest look at where things
are currently at and where the use of
digital actors could likely go in the
near future
[Music]
so first off we have been replacing
actors with digital performances for
years in this first example we're going
to look at is from The Curious Case of
Benjamin Button old man Brad Pitt he was
born an old man an old baby his born-old
baby
oh my God
he is born an old baby
oh
seven but I look a lot older definitely
on Kenny Valley right off the bat this
has aged this came out in 2008 at the
time it completely fooled me I had no
idea how they did it so this is an
example of one of the earliest forms of
emotion capture where you put all the
dots on the face and you get an actor to
perform and we're able to translate
those performances onto a digital render
we actually had Paul De bevik on the
vfxrs react Show recently and he was one
of the guys instrumental in creating
this technology so that was really cool
there's something about this now that
isn't quite working we're definitely in
The Uncanny Valley here even though the
craftsmanship here is very good
something about this has age so what is
that what what jumps out to you here
first thing to me which is always the
first thing is the eyes and there's a
lifelessness to it that's really hard to
capture and it's so weird because all of
this uncanny feeling is derived from the
subconscious right by means of evolution
or by means of just the amount of reps
that we have looking at a human face I
can tell that you are real I hope I'm
right I hope this doesn't age poorly but
oh good lord uh but the closer that we
get to that that real feeling the the
more perfect you have to be because that
uncanny trigger man it just it's this
natural innate creepy feeling the
rendering also isn't quite up to what
we're used to these days like we've got
a lot better at rendering skin that's
pretty clear too so an example where the
rendering quality is significantly
better is actually Rachel from Blade
Runner 2049 this is an example of like
some of the best digital humans we had
ever done Circa late 2010s here she
comes you know now that it actually has
been a few years it's oh actually it
gets a lot better the closer she gets to
camera pulling off a photorealistic
still image is infinitely simpler than
pulling off a photorealistic thing in
motion which is where they do such a
good job here man she's not doing that
much the trick here is
here is head the hair everything about
the face and the head is CG this took a
team of artists something like two years
to be able to really dive in and
research and develop this look in order
to get the technology good enough to
match the original Rachel look look at
that look at that dude that's pretty
good honestly the the fake Rachel looks
more real than the real Rachel because
they have that one-to-one reference it's
the minute you step out of the reference
and add the motion I mean the Artistry
really needs to ramp up the weakest part
about this whole sequence is the moment
she talks and it's just a single line
don't you love me
we can immediately tell it's like okay
that there's something up with the lips
because lip animation is still one of
the hardest things to do dude I mean
you're talking about a face that has 43
muscles and 10 000 possible human
expressions
during that that kind of complex
combination of musculature and the
relationships between them is beyond
what I think humans can even wrap their
heads around it's challenging because we
as humans require literally 100.00
percent like fully realistic accuracy in
order to not at least get a major dosing
of uncanny valley the minute that you
are thinking about visual effects in a
way you've lost as close as you have
possibly gotten to achieving it if we
are talking fully replacing actors with
total photorealism a hundred percent you
need to cross that last threshold and
keep us from thinking about visual
effects So speaking of some digital
performances that we all did notice the
Irishman had some
damn it the Irishman Stars some old
dudes uh Robert De Niro Joe Pesci uh
Pacino who the are you the effects
we see here are an attempt to basically
create actors in a state that they don't
currently exist in their younger selves
so what we're getting in these younger
characters are old dude performances
such as this
oh how old are you supposed to be here
mid 30s mid 40s look at his arm his
right arm have you ever seen a 30 year
old or 40 year old do that it's all so
like stiff and it's not his fault I
can't stress that enough it's just the
limitation it's like you change the face
but the body the bones the joints the
meat like that has already aged and
there's nothing you could do to fix that
performance outside of a full CG
character I get the reasoning behind it
they try to stay true to the
performances of these legendary actors
but this is an example where they
probably should have actually had a body
double a younger body double that had
that spryeness fit that build a little
bit better I think people might have
accepted that a little bit more
stripping all of this conversation away
I still can't believe that we can do
this this is remarkable work but what
we're talking about is making up that
last half of a percent so I think
probably an example of the best visual
effects the world has ever seen up until
this point is from Avatar 2.
what I love about WETA is when they come
into contact with a limitation they
Brute Force bash its head in man they
just kicked the door in and they expand
what's possible and they did the same
thing with facial capture technology for
this film this is a great example of the
ultimate evolution of emotion capture
you know we saw this with Thanos we're
now incorporating more AI tools into
everything to really figure out the
subtleties of the actual musculature
motion underneath the skin it's the
perfect application of machine learning
because you're right there's so much
Nuance to it it's just too much for a
human mind to to think about and they
designed essentially a neural network
that was trained on muscle relationships
you're talking the face you're talking
the eyes the lips and increases the
Fidelity of the performance that you get
through animation but there's a caveat
to all of this incredible work this is
animation that is existing on Aliens
right exact aliens I've only seen a
couple
we'll talk about that later
why is that a caveat because you do not
have to deal with The Uncanny Valley as
much there's an emotional disconnect
from knowing that we're seeing an alien
face it's still able to emote in all of
the same ways we're familiar with so
we're able to still see the accurate
performances and we're able to still
have that emotional connection with the
character without triggering that part
of our lizard brain that goes wait a
minute that not people so let's go ahead
and take a look at where things could go
from here generative AI is like the
current hot button you know chat GPT mid
Journey all this stuff's coming out now
but like AI tools have been doing this
stuff for years deep fakes have
literally been around for years defects
being an artificial intelligence
implementation of effects we at Corridor
have been making deep fix for over four
years now granted looking back at this
now the quality of it is very rough this
is uncanny valley like for sure the
quality of deep fakes have gotten so
much better in the last few years we
were ahead of the curve as far as like
Studios adopting this but I think the
most recent example of an actual deep
fake finally being used is Luke
Skywalker and Boba Fett I think this is
the best example of the first deep fake
being used in an actual cinematic
production and multiple scenes across
multiple episodes with young Mark Hamill
playing Luke Skywalker Luke in the scene
is objectively good like yeah that looks
amazing very good like performance comes
through the rendering comes through I'd
say this is like at the 99.99 I'll give
it now yeah the first time I actually
saw this scene I would forget I'd be
like man this looks incredible but then
I get distracted by the actual moments
and I'm watching it and then like a
couple minutes goes by and I realized
wait a minute I totally forgot that I
was looking at a fake Luke I would say
this totally proves the points that we
can replace an actor the quality is
there and they figured out a pipeline to
be able to get multiple minutes out of a
performance here and what we're seeing
too is exponential growth in every
aspect it's like getting better and
better faster and faster the constraint
isn't technological anymore it's
economical yes very much that's the
constraints it still probably cost a
tremendous amount of money because it
was still a lot of effort at the end of
the day to create this character at some
point that cost is going to come down
enough absolutely that it becomes
economical to make a movie starring
young Luke Skywalker so can we really
replace actors yeah we just looked up a
lot of evidence of that happening but
the question is like can you actually
fully replace actors at scale like
throughout an entire show I mean
everything we've looked at up until now
has obviously still required a
performance there's still an actor
that's needed they haven't actually been
replaced right now with the actors
strike going on a lot of their fears are
kind of forward-thinking they're seeing
the writing on the wall when it comes to
AI they're trying to get ahead of it and
they're like this is going to evolve
faster than we can imagine they're right
how should actors be compensated or how
should rights be handled here I don't
have the answers to any of that right
now but let's look at some Grim
realities of the situation what's going
to be possible sooner than later is I
think background actors are going to go
away well we're already at the point
where Crowds Are Gone oh exactly when
he's gone Stadium's gone Incredible
movies from way back in the day like Ben
Hur Gladiator you have hundreds of
extras making up the background dude if
you thought parking at a Taylor Swift
concert was bad you should have seen the
Ben Hur said okay
that was the reality of filmmaking back
in the day you literally had to have
hundreds of people if you wanted to have
hundreds of people yeah that's not been
the case for decades now right Lord of
the Rings invented this program called
massive having armies Collide you could
simulate all of that without having to
actually cast thousands of people I
think we're at a point where sooner than
later sooner than you realize much
simpler scenes like a busy restaurant
will have background characters that are
fully CGI even though that has been
possible technically for a while now
it's never been economical but as visual
Effects productions go more and more
real time we're very rapidly approaching
a time where you can just type something
new for all 50 tables in the background
of the scene it's automatically
generated animated and rendered and
placed into the scene at the moment of
filming the ethical conversations
surrounding that are complicated
background acting is the way you get
into the film industry as an actor and
into the Union you know so many people's
First Union Gig was because they were a
background actor on something it's true
but ultimately even if the background
actors are replaced there will still be
a need for the main cast to you know
deliver key performances but what
happens when even that actor doesn't
need to be there anymore that seems like
it's a long way off it does yeah is it
not so yesterday this guy recorded a
clip for me and he sent it to me and I
want to show you this clip real quick
hybrid from cover their crew thanks for
your wait is a personalized video for
you Ryan yeah yeah he made a
personalized video for me figuring out
if it is really possible to replace
actors and whether or not that is
possible right now we will get back to
you soon by the way this is an automated
video message generated with my avatar
hope you like it and talk soon prove it
prove it can he prove it all right dude
the neck look at the the the the deck
this is generated from nothing from
nothing there's no actor driving this
performance how are you so calm right
now I was already familiar with this
company though they specialize in
creating digital avatars for like
corporate videos for instance okay hi
everyone I'm Andrew from hey Jam
obviously they've got a a voice model
trained on these actors voices or this
guy's voice and they have a face model
trained on what he looks like but also
his mannerisms yeah it's like deep fake
blend shape everything in between all
together algorithmically cemented this
is not at that 100 level of quality yet
there's some towels it's like you can
kind of tell there's a little bit of
stutteriness as it transitions between
different words and mannerisms well it
got me I mean it's like it's stunning
and I don't know what they're using
under the you know the covers here or
the range of what's possible I mean
everything's to camera from what I'm
seeing the range of this is limited I
can't say have this guy run down the
street and jump over a car and then say
I'll be back but like we've never really
seen this before I mean you got my
caveman seeing wheel for the first time
reaction there like this is all an
example of where we're at right now with
a little bit of a look into what's
coming but let's take a moment to
imagine the far future a little bit did
you see the the episode of Black Mirror
called Joan is awful yes I did too if
you're familiar with that show you know
what we're about to talk about but let
me paint a picture for you you come home
from work you've had a long day you sit
down at your TV and you just want to
relax and watch a movie and instead of
just browsing Netflix and choosing a
movie to watch you're like TV play a
movie starring me and all my friends and
make it like an action comedy and then
the TV not only generates in real time a
movie starring you and all your friends
it's like oscar-winning good it's hard
to believe that that could be possible
think about it this way two years ago if
I told you you can just open up this
chat box and type in some words and the
most beautiful cinematic picture would
be sitting in front of you from that
description you would not believe me
yeah and here we are just two years
later and it's not only possible
everyone's just grown numb to it isn't
that nuts how fast we grew into that I
do believe at least for the foreseeable
future performances are still going to
be very important and that requires
actors to be in those roles it's one
thing for something to be like CGI and
synthetic but they're still an artist
creating that they're still the human
touch most people don't understand how
CGI is made so they kind of just assume
you're pressing buttons on a computer
and I think that's where some of the CGI
hate comes from because of their
misunderstanding of the Artistry that
goes into it now we're ending a world
where that is actually true it is
actually just pressing a button and
content is generated you're so right
without regulation this stuff can become
problems people used to die on film sets
all the time because there weren't any
safety regulations and that's the fear
is that if this continues in an
unregulated fashion without any sort of
Rights placed on like the actors who
owns your likeness this might become a
situation where there are no more acting
roles in Hollywood because it's all just
generated on the fly when you get home
and I think the agreements that they're
coming to right now are very important
it's crucial it's crucial because this
is so much more of the Wild West Than
People realize because most people
aren't paying attention but I think the
most important thing to keep in mind is
that yes while progress will not slow
our preparation can increase and it
seems like that's what they're doing and
that's what we need to focus on are you
guys scared of this too I'm curious of
your thoughts is where do you think this
is going leave a comment down below kind
of giving me your perspective I'm very
interested in continuing this
conversation but there's one thing that
I do know and it's that I was never real
the whole time